now it isn't just porn or CRT there's a
new nefarious undertaking that's taking
place in our schools it's called climate
Justice and activist masquerading as
teachers are trying to turn our kids
into these little green acts and
training
a new bill in Minnesota would require
all schools in the state to implement a
climate Justice education program by the
2025-26 school year the bill describes
it as a framework that puts people first
and Views the effects of climate change
as interconnected with forms of
Oppression
connecting climate change to Social and
economic justice issues now Zach
Duckworth is a Minnesota State senator
and former School administrator who is
opposing this push Senator the number of
K-12 students in your state
who are meeting grade level standards
for reading
is just a bit over 50 percent
while less than half are proficient in
math and science so why the focus then
on climate Justice
well Laura you're asking the right
question you know as a former School
Board member uh some of those statistics
you just read off are disheartening and
I can tell you that parents had a pretty
uniform message when I was on the school
board and that was to keep politics out
of the classroom let's focus on helping
our kids succeed academically
teaching little kids how to read and uh
so they can be successful this certainly
doesn't help us prioritize that so in
Maine they're learning about you know
pornographic content in sixth grade
and in Minnesota K-12
it seems like they're being
propagandized to become
oppositional to more may perhaps
traditionally minded parents on the
climate front
um is there widespread disagreement on
this on this issue in the public at
large there or is everybody in Minnesota
just Frozen in the head at this point
well we might be frozen a bit uh to be
honest with you however uh what I can
say is when it comes to the instruction
in the classroom and our kids parents
want to prioritize the basic academic
standards and traditional things that
kids are taught that are going to allow
them to succeed Reading Writing Math
Science and here's the deal we're having
we have so many kids that face such
disruption in the classroom over the
last couple of years because they were
kind of shut out and what we need to be
doing is prioritizing the very things
that are going to help them catch up and
succeed rather than any one party's
political agenda yeah Governor Walsh is
a huge disappointment in this uh level
now Senator I want to play this from the
Bill's sponsor this is from a senate
hearing just last week
in terms of this being political
you know if we we still have some flat
earthers out there honestly climate
change if you talk to actual scientists
actual climatologists and the fact that
humans are accelerating what is going on
is as as close as you're going to get to
Scientific consensus out there on any
topic so if you don't want this taught
in school
um you're just a flat earther is that
what we're to conclude
you know there's something to be said
for local control and allowing school
boards the communities and parents to
decide what they want their kids to be
taught there's no one out there that's
debating whether or not we should be
good stewards of the environment you
have no further to look than Minnesota
Farmers or Farmers all across our
country that would say yeah we're going
to take care of our environment but what
we should be doing is teaching or
professing a lot of these politically
motivated aspects of what this bill
would be proposing
Zach thank you so much great to see you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else